[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und mitri sirin ihnen allen einen
schönen guten abend heute haben viele
das wort endlich benutzt und zwar im
zusammenhang mit einer bewegung die es
in einer nervenaufreibenden hängepartie
gibt das hier ist es frachtschiff sony
heute morgen gegen 8 uhr 20 in odessa an
bord rund 26.000 tonnen mais zielhafen
libanon wo sie dringend auf diese aber
auch auf andere getreide warten morgen
soll das schiff am bosporus einlaufen
inspiziert werden von vertretern
russlands der ukraine den vereinten
nationen und der türkei
vielleicht ist es ein erster
hoffnungsvoller schritt trotzdem wirft
er fragen auf dazu gleich mehr mit
unserem korrespondenten lück wahl bot in
istanbul die tatsache dass es jetzt
viele positive reaktionen auf diese
schiffsbewegung gibt kann aber nicht
darüber hinwegtäuschen wie gefährlich
wie riskant die situation im osten und
süden der ukraine nach wie vor ist
unsere reporterin anne brühl hat dies
heute in mikolajki verfahren hier ist
gericht
wir sind mit der polizei nicolai
verabredet deren arbeit heißt in diesem
krieg frischer raketeneinschläge
begutachten wie den am örtlichen
krankenhaus die stadt liegt nicht weit
von der front entfernt plötzlich werden
wir unterbrochen
ja
das ist das habt ihr täglich
zehnmal am tag gibt das luftalarm die
sirenen ertönen tag und nacht letzte
woche war es meistens nachts aber es
kann immer passieren
und dann müssen wir runter in den bunker
mehrere treppen immer tiefer in den
keller des krankenhauses der soll schutz
bieten falls russische raketen wieder
hof mikola fliegen der bunker ist ein
dunkles labyrinth von kleinen räumen
überall liegen kauern menschen patienten
angestellte des krankenhauses aber auch
kinder
ich war hier
letzte nacht hat die russische
föderation uns angegriffen
da waren raketen die erste war ein
bisschen weg von der gynäkologie und
dann wurde der vierte stock getroffen
sie kümmern sich nicht um das leben von
ukraine sie möchten dass wir uns vor
ihnen verstecken
svetlana ist froh dass ihr mann bei ihr
ist warum bleibt ihr in nicolai
ich bin ein soldat in kharkiv
und mein sohn wartet auch darauf zur
armee zu gehen und meine frau die wartet
auf uns
auf dem flur stehen betten neun
verletzte gab es diesmal alleine auf
tatjana station
wenn ich schlecht habe und der alarm
ertönt gehen wir hier runter und leben
so
viele unserer mitarbeiter haben
gekündigt es ist sehr sehr hart
tatiana muss zurück auf ihre stationen
zurück in den alltag 30 minuten warten
sie immer nach dem alarm wenn dann
nichts passiert ist geht für sie die
arbeit einfach weiter
der bericht von einer brücke gehen
nochmal zu den getreide ausfuhren und
nach istanbul zurück weil port glück ein
schiff hat abgelegt aber es müssen noch
viele weitere ablegen damit sich
hungerkrisen nicht zuspitzen gibt es die
überhaupt diese schiffe und wie soll das
organisiert werden wenn schon bei einem
es so lange dauert
also die schiffe gibt es auf jeden fall
aber die frage nach der organisation ist
mehr als berechtigt es wird sehr lange
dauern diese prozedur die der standort
postler die da ausgearbeitet wurde ist
etwas schwerfällig nämlich die schiffe
werden bei der ausfahrt aus odessa hier
am bosporus kontrolliert von diesen
experten jeweils der ukraine russlands
der vereinten nationen und der türkei
und die leeren schiffe die nach odessa
auf dem weg sind werden auch
kontrolliert ob sie denn wirklich leer
sind das haben die russen durchgesetzt
bei den verhandlungen das wird also sehr
zeitaufwendig werden und da sind wir
beim zweiten problem im moment liegen
mindestens 17 beladene schiffe 1 heute
ausgelaufen also noch 16 beladene
schiffe in den drei helfen der region
odessa die werden auf jeden fall so
heißt es hier in expertenkreisen bei
reedereien raus kommen weil auch die
besitzer die reedereien ein interesse
daran daran haben diese schiffe die
teilweise monate dort fest lagen
rauszubekommen aber die nächste frage
ist dann werden wirklich lehre schiffe
nach odessa sich auf den weg machen da
ist die frage der sicherheit der cruze
also der mannschaften aber eben auch der
versicherungen die sind enorm gestiegen
die versicherungspolicen für diese
schiffe die dort nach odessa wollen und
da stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
teuer wird dann die fracht und wird es
dann nicht einfach zu teuer auch für die
abnehmer zwischen libanon und kongo also
das sind eine menge fragen die noch
geklärt werden müssen und das ist ein
richtiger schritt das schiff wird morgen
abend hier erwartet den istanbul in die
richtige richtung aber es ist noch lange
nicht die lösung des problems sagt unser
korrespondent in istanbul lück wort
vielen dank
hochangespannte situation auch zwischen
den usa und china
ein konflikt mit erheblichem
eskalationspotenzial ist dass er schon
länger spielt jüngste provokation ist
die ankündigung der vorsitzenden des us
repräsentantenhauses pelosi während
ihrer asien reise taiwan zu besuchen
so berichtet dass unter anderem der us
senders cnn dass hier bilder mit
singapurs premierminister von heute
china betrachtet taiwan als teil der
volksrepublik und lehnt besuche
ausländischer politiker grundsätzlich ab
demonstrativ hat china in den
vergangenen tagen manöver in der nähe
taiwans abgehalten peking droht mit
konsequenzen und sieht in einem besuch
eine krasse einmischung in innere
angelegenheiten
wir wollen nach new york in zu elmar
theveßen elmar sollte per los sie
tatsächlich taiwan besuchen wäre das ja
eine extreme zuspitzung des konfliktes
warum diese provokation zu diesem
zeitpunkt
bei dieser reise eben schon im april
geplant war damals wusste man auch dass
sie einen abstecher nach taiwan machen
könnte und damals gab es keine so
heftigen reaktionen aus peking darauf
jetzt wird diese reise nachgeholt sie
war im april corona krank geworden und
jetzt auf einmal gibt es diese heftigen
drohungen mann erklärt sich dass hier
damit das schiff in ping innenpolitisch
in china so sehr unter druck steht dass
er irgendwie antworten muss und zwar
sehr deutlich aber auch nancy pelosi ist
in der zwickmühle reist sie nicht dann
würde das als einknicken gesehen reißt
sie eben könnte das ungewollte
nebenwirkungen haben im weißen haus ist
man nicht wirklich glücklich über einen
möglichen abstecher nach taiwan aber man
sagt das muss die sprecherin des
repräsentantenhauses alleine entscheiden
es gibt die gewaltenteilung in den usa
man sagt es gilt weiter die
ein-china-politik für die us-regierung
aber man warnt davor dass es zu einer
eskalation kommen könnte deswegen fährt
gerade der us flugzeugträger ronald
reagan in die straße von taiwan ein und
man hofft dass man missverständnisse in
den nächsten tagen vermeiden kann aber
die lage wird wohl in den nächsten tagen
sehr angespannt sein also sehr ernsten
situation danke für die schilderung nach
new york elmar theveßen
während wir im urlaub sind oder ist noch
vorhaben begeben sich menschen jedes
jahr auf eine tot- gefährliche flucht
über das mittelmeer
mehrere dutzend wurden gerade gestern
wieder von einem boot aufgegriffen
allein in den letzten fünf jahren haben
das mehr als 10.000 flüchtende nicht
überlebt eine schande für europa so oder
so ähnlich äußern sich eu politiker
immer wieder bei seenot unglücken
geändert hat sich bis heute eigentlich
nicht so viel seit jahren rettet die
organisationsteam watch in seenot
geratene personen vor dem ertrinken
italien setzte dann zwei schiffe dieser
organisation fest weil sie laut behörden
nicht dafür ausgelegt seien hunderte
menschen an bord zu nehmen dagegen
klagte sie watch und bekam heute vom
europäischen gerichtshof teilweise recht
mehr von christian von rechenberg
talent süditalien aktuelle bilder vom
einsatz von swatch
444 menschen sicher an land gebracht vor
knapp einer woche waren die noch in
lebensgefahr
irgendwo auf dem mittelmeer von europa
sich selbst überlassen und den zufall
die privaten organisationen schließen
eine rettungs lücke ihnen stärkte der
ogh heute den rücken unser ziel war es
außerordentliche und politisch
motivierte hafenstadt kontrollen zu
verhindern denen sind wir heute in
großen schritt näher gekommen weil uns
der ogh in zentralen punkten recht
gegeben hat das ein großer erfolg für
uns hafen staatskontrolle das recht
eines staates jedem schiff in seinen
häfen einen prüfenden besuch abzustatten
auch außer der reihe politisch motiviert
oder nicht italien suchte und fand bei
diesen kontrollen gründe die schiffe von
sea watch festzuhalten monate lang
dreimal binnen zwei jahren wegen mängeln
und walter etwas fehlte italien hat von
uns unter anderem die registrierung als
rettungsschiff gefordert der euro hat
klar festgestellt dass dies nicht nötig
ist sondern dass unsere deutsche
registrierung die wir vollständig
erfüllen absolut ausreichend für das was
wir tun was sie auch tut ist in den
augen der kontrolleure regelmäßig mehr
menschen an bord zu nehmen als
zugelassen sind doch das so der ogh
heute reiche nicht für eine kontrolle
die ist zwar erlaubt aber nur wenn es
belastende anhaltspunkte für gefahren an
bord gibt was die behörden den cruze
sodann an maßnahmen auferlegen müsse zu
dem verhältnismäßig sein einer der sich
unentwegt für die cbot schiffe und gegen
ihre festsetzung stark gemacht hatte ist
heute erleichtert das urteil hat
ausdrücklich auch noch einmal die
notwendigkeit von seenotrettung für
menschen die in lebensgefahr sind
bestätigt und es hat klare
einschränkungen von solchen möglichen
blockierungen der seenotrettung schütte
die schiffe in den italienischen häfen
festgelegt daran muss man sich jetzt
halten aus italien dazu heute kein wort
das war mal anders
2009 10 mit großem getöse sperrte der
damalige innenminister matteo salvini
die swatch 3 auf dem meer aus kapitänin
rakete widersetzt sich muss vor gericht
flucht und migration ewige
wahlkampfthemen in italien noch immer
politisch ist das vorgehen der
nachfolgeregierung sicher weniger rigide
als die politik salvinis damals war die
seenotrettung ein politikum heute ist
die situation allerdings nicht besser
denn ist es eigentlich gleich ob man die
schiffe nicht in den hafen rein lässt
oder ob man sie nicht wieder hinaus
lässt sie fehlen auf dem meer sie fehlen
auf dem mittelmeer wo sie menschen
retten müssen und so hoffen sie bei
swatch ist ihre arbeit nun leichter wird
und sind trotzdem vorbereitet auf die
kreativität der kontrolleure
unsere zeit ist gerade von krieg und
krisen geprägter findet in new york eine
überprüfungskonferenz zum
atomwaffensperrvertrag
stadt das ist ein guter anlass auf
abrüstung auf atomare abrüstung zu
drängen
angesichts der krisen weltweit hat
un-generalsekretär gute risch dringend
gefordert weiter an der reduzierung von
atomwaffen zu arbeiten
bei der eröffnung der konferenz sagte er
die menschheit sei nur ein
missverständnis eine faire berechnung
von der nuklearen vernichtung entfernt
auch außenministerin bernburg sprach
sich in new york für atomare abrüstung
aus dass zugleich auch in deutschland us
atomwaffen stationiert bleiben
bündnisverpflichtungen geschuldet
der einsatz für nukleare
nichtverbreitung und nukleare
abschreckung sind in diesen zeiten kein
widerspruch der brutale angriffskrieg
russlands macht deutlich dass
nuklearwaffen leider eine bittere
realität sind und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir auch im strategischen
konzept der nato deutlich gemacht haben
die nukleare teilhabe ist teil des
bündnisses der nato und zugleich
unterstreichen dass die nato für
nukleare abrüstung und kontrolle
einsteht
in deutschland dauert die debatte über
eine verlängerung der laufzeiten der
drei atomkraftwerke die noch in betrieb
sind an es müsse diskutiert werden ob
das möglich sei sagte
mecklenburg-vorpommerns
ministerpräsidenten schwesig spd dem
sender welt.tv es dürfe keine
denkverbote geben sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann von der
cdu plädierte in handelsblatt sogar für
eine verlängerung von atomkraft auf
unbestimmte zeit
der europäische gerichtshof hat mehrere
deutsche regelungen zum umgang mit
flüchtlingen und migranten gekippt so
müssen deutsche behörden künftig einen
antrag auf schutz gründen auf
familiennachzug genehmigen auch wenn
minderjährige während des verfahrens
volljährig werden außerdem haben aus
eu-staaten zugezogene künftig anspruch
auf kindergeld in den ersten drei
monaten des aufenthalts auch unabhängig
von einer erwerbstätigkeit bislang
erhielt nur die zugezogenen kindergeld
die hier arbeiteten
seit einer woche brennt es im
nationalpark sächsische schweiz die
löscharbeiten sind wegen der vielen
glutnester schwierig der bund werde sich
an den kosten beteiligen sagte
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht
sachsens ministerpräsident kretschmann
bei einem besuch im waldbrandgebiet zu
auch im angrenzenden tschechischen
nationalpark böhmische schweiz ist das
feuer noch nicht unter kontrolle
900 feuerwehrleute kämpfen dort gegen
die flammen
in wien haben am abend hunderte menschen
einer ärztin gedacht die sich vor
einigen tagen das leben genommen hatte
mit einer mahnwache am stephansdom
die medizinerin war von imf und corona
maßnahmen gegnern monatelang
eingeschüchtert und angefeindet worden
wegen morddrohungen stand sie zeitweise
unter polizeischutz ihre praxis schloss
sie schließlich weil sie sich nicht
ausreichend von polizei und behörden
gegen die angriffe geschützt sei
gemessen an der zahl derer die noch
maske tragen beschleicht einen das
gefühl so richtig ernst genommen wird
krone nicht mehr aber die kontroversen
um maßnahmen nehmen zu und da geht es im
kern immer um das ausloten von
sicherheit und freiheit sowie zuletzt
bei der forderung des kassen- ärztechef
gassen der eine aufhebung der quarantäne
pflicht ins spiel bringt in schweden und
großbritannien gilt es schon seit heute
auch bei unseren nachbarn in österreich
aus wien wolf christian ullrich bei
kaiserwetter mag man keinesfalls in
quarantäne und tatsächlich geht ab heute
in österreich der korona hat aber keine
symptome darf in die öffentlichkeit wenn
auch mit maske ich bin der meinung dass
die quarantäne sowieso schon lange passé
sein sollte wenn es coronas lieber
daheim bevor es andere leute dann an
steaks vorbei die zeit der
abstandswarner und während warner corona
ist jetzt normal dass die botschaft des
bundeskanzlers der seine parteifreunde
jüngst so auf die neue zeit ein stimmt
so viele
warum heißt auch so viele viren aber
jetzt hat es uns nicht mehr wie viren
kümmern nicht mehr man müsse bei krone
vom krisen zum akzeptanz modus finden
als ein gesundheitsminister nun das ende
der quarantäne im fernsehen erklären
soll verrät den größeren kontext und ich
kann den müssen einfach darauf schauen
dass wir in anbetracht eine situation im
herbst nicht leichter wird mit teuerung
mit der energiefrage ein
gesellschaftliches klima schaffen wo wir
in ruhe und ordnung einen weg gehen mit
dieser pandemie zu leben corona zum
normalfall machen weil andere krisen
drohen gesundheitsexperten die die
regierung beraten sind mit dem
quarantäne ende nicht einverstanden das
aus wissenschaftlicher sicht
ist es schwierig diesen schritt zu
unterstützen man darf nicht denn dem
trugschluss auflegen das wenn man keine
symptome dass man deshalb nicht
infektiös ist selbst im krankenhaus
dürfen mitarbeiter mit corona die sich
fit fühlen arbeiten so die neue regelung
doch viele krankenhausbetreiber wollen
dieses risiko nicht tragen wir haben
glaube ich die meisten träger in
österreich beschlossen dass wir zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter die positiv
aber symptomfrei sind nicht in die
spitäler hinein holen lieber wenig
regeln als viel erklären die neue corona
politik der schwammigen vorne der
abschaffung der quarantäne nun
epidemiologisch richtig oder falsch ist
der politik und
kommunikationswissenschaftler ist
fassungslos weil schon wieder
verunsichert wurde mit widersprüchlicher
kommunikation kommunikation ist
fehlanzeige
der sommer ist einfach zu schön für
corona und was im herbst passiert wird
in österreich im herbst entschieden
es war ein ungleicher kampf und
eigentlich hoffnungslos
inspiriert vom widerstand im warschauer
ghetto wählten auch circa 25.000
soldaten der polnischen untergrundarmee
die bewaffnete gegenwehr als antwort auf
den übermächtigen besatzer terror der
deutschen dieser ungleiche kampf begann
heute vor 78 jahren und dauerte 63 lange
tage hitler befahl seinen hoch
überlegenen ss und wehrmacht
brutal zurückzuschlagen geschätzt
200.000 soldaten und zivilisten starben
heute wurde an den mutigen warschauer
aufstand erinnert über den umgang mit
diesen historischen trauma konnte
natalie steger mit zwei zeitzeugen
sprechen
sie waren noch teenager als sie zur
waffe griffen gegen die deutschen
besatzer jesus stick und joseph
mankiewicz am denkmal des warschauer
aufstand mit der polnischen heimatarmee
lehnten sie sich damals gegen die
peiniger auf
ich war zweimal bei der aktion der
entwaffnung von deutschen dabei das gab
uns schrecklich viel genugtuung dass wir
zwerge im alter von 17 einen erwachsenen
mann entwaffnet haben
obwohl ich 15 jahre alt war fühlte ich
mich wie ein erwachsener der nicht
kämpfte gegen den feind gemeinsam mit
den erwachsenen
am ersten august 1944 beginnt die
polnische heimatarmee im untergrund den
kampf gegen die deutschen die hoffnung
die hauptstadt aus eigener kraft zu
befreien 63 tage dauert der aufstand bis
in die wehrmacht niederschlägt aus rache
legen die deutschen fast die komplette
stadt in schutt und asche begehen
massenmorde
punkt 17 uhr eine schweigeminute
genau um diese zeit begann der aufstand
der warschauer vor 78 jahren da sitzen
sie die die überlebten seit' an seit'
wie damals alle erinnerungen gehen mir
durch den kopf das heulen der sirenen
der enthusiasmus der leute ich habe mit
meinen eigenen augen gesehen als die
leute ziemlich gute möbel aus dem
fenster geworfen haben um sofort
barrikaden bauern zu können
polens nationalkonservative regierung
macht zuletzt verstärkt mit dem thema
deutscher reparationszahlungen stimmung
will in einem monat einen bericht dazu
vorlegen
die heutigen deutschen müssen sich im
klaren darüber sein es ist keine rede
davon dass man ohne echte genugtuung
dieses kapitel der geschichte schließen
kann
der warschauer aufstand bis heute in der
stadt an vielen stellen symbole zu sehen
familientage wir erinnern uns
eingebrannt ins kollektive gedächtnis
der polen und doch wollen zeitzeugen
auch nach vorne schauen in der zeit der
okkupation hieß es wenn man deutsch auf
der straße hörte dass es menschen jagd
war sie schossen die menschen hatten
angst
heute wenn ich die deutsche sprache
höhere nehme ich sie einfach als sprache
ich weiß dass ich in ruhe mit den
nachbarn leben wäre die erinnerung an
den freiheitskampf an die qualen der
besatzung wachhalten vor allem aber
lehren daraus ziehen sagen die die es
erlebt haben
bei uns jetzt nochmal weitere
nachrichten mit diakon dollar
infolge der pandemie des krieges und der
hohen inflation hat der deutsche
einzelhandel den größten umsatzeinbruch
seit 28 jahren zu verkraften die zahlen
des statistischen bundesamtes zeigen
dramatische veränderungen im
einkaufsverhalten stefanie bareth was
schätzen denn die experten wann wird
wieder mehr konsumiert
also experten sehen auf absehbare zeit
jedenfalls keinen konsumboom am horizont
auf den hatte ja der einzelhandel nach
dem auslaufen der korona maßnahmen
sehnsüchtig gehofft aber die
shoppinglaune ist in deutschland vorerst
vergangen verbraucher sind bei einkäufen
und anschaffungen zurückhaltend wie
lange nicht mehr und sie halten ihr geld
einfach zusammen denn sie fürchten
steigende preise und vor allem
unkalkulierbare
energiekosten die uns im herbst über den
kopf wachsen könnten gespart wird
deshalb auf breiter front so fiel der
umsatz im deutschen einzelhandel
insgesamt im juni um fast neun prozent
gegenüber dem vorjahr besonders hart
traf es den textilhandel für bekleidung
schuhe und lederwaren gaben die kunden
gut zehn prozent weniger aus auch bei
lebensmitteln schauen die menschen
wieder auf den cent hier gingen die
umsätze um rund sieben prozent zurück
und selbst im seit corona blumen den
online-versandhandel sanken die umsätze
im juni um 15 prozent zahlen die belegen
der binnenkonsum als wichtige stütze der
wirtschaftsentwicklung könnte zunehmend
ins wanken geraten umso dringender dass
die politik nun rasch die richtigen
weichen gestellt um einkommensschwache
haushalte gezielt zu stärken denn auch
die gas umlage die verbrauchern zum
ersten oktober noch droht ist derzeit
eine große unbekannte in der
haushaltsrechnung so ist es vielen dank
stephanie in frankfurt
das zdf trauert um joachim jauer unser
langjähriger korrespondent ist im alter
von 82 jahren gestorben
er sei ein brückenbauer zwischen ost und
west gewesen erklärte chefredakteur
peter frey drei jahrzehnte lang habe ja
hellsichtig und kritisch unter anderem
aus der ddr berichtet moderierte
kennzeichen die leitete auch die zdf
studios in berlin und wien unvergessen
sein bericht vom abbau der grenzanlagen
zwischen ungarn und österreich im mai
im augenblick vor über 40 jahren wurde
quer durch europa die absperrung
errichtet die der britische staatsmann
winston churchill den eisernen vorhang
nannte heute beendet ungarn an dieser
stelle die gewaltsame teilung von ost
und west
joachim jauer auch heute rollte der ball
im dfb pokal die bundesligisten taten
sich diesmal schwer setzten sich am ende
aber durch so hat sich werder bremen für
die zweite hauptrunde qualifiziert
ebenso wie union berlin und zweitligist
darmstadt 98 ist ebenfalls weiter mit
dem sieg gegen ingolstadt
ja weiter mit fußball es bleibt dabei
wer ein großes spiel wie gestern das em
finale verliert kann sich natürlich
nicht sofort freuen über ein grandios
gespielt das turnier über ansehnlichen
und technisch raffinierten
offensivfußball und so sah es dann auch
nach schlusspfiff aus bei den deutschen
fußballerinnen flossen tränen sie waren
wirklich sehr nah dran und irgendwie
beschreibt das ziemlich treffend das
legendäre fußballer zitat von wegmann
erst hatten wir kein glück und dann kam
auch noch pech dazu heute aber da
konnten sie wieder strahlen über die
triumphale und umjubelte rückkehr nach
frankfurt zum römer aris donzelli
fast ein wenig ungläubig treten lina
magull und ihre teamkolleginnen raus auf
den balkon am frankfurter römer sie
erleben einen zuspruch wie er bei einem
titelgewinn nicht viel größer hätte sein
können um kurz vor halb drei am
nachmittag die mannschaft kehrt nach
frankfurt zurück mit viel hoffnung im
gepäck
ich glaube was wir auch in diesem
turnier gezeigt haben nicht dass wir nur
die spiele gewonnen haben sondern mit
der art und weise wie wir die spiele
gewonnen haben und dass man mit
teamgeist mit zusammenhalt einfach ganz
ganz viel schaffen kann und erreichen
kann 51 tage lang haben sie zusammenhalt
gelebt füreinander miteinander
[Applaus]
tragt die werte die wir wirklich
vorgelebt haben trat die werte in
unserer gesellschaft
dann werden ein stück weit besser und
wir haben sie verdient
87.000 zuschauer haben das finale im
wembley gesehen und die kleinigkeiten
die entscheidend waren alexander popp
kurzfristig verletzt da ein
pfostenschuss von marcoule dort ein
nicht gegebener elfmeter nach einem
handspiel von williamson
lina magull store zum ausgleich
und englands glückstreffer
aus dem getümmel
[Applaus]
schalker square in london die party-zone
der löwinnen tausende feiern england
titelgewinn der boulevard spiegelt
wieder worauf das land des fußballs ewig
gewartet hatte die frauen haben
geliefert jetzt heißt es die gunst der
stunde zu nutzen
bundeskanzlers scholz hat dem deutschen
team hilfe angeboten will nachhaltigkeit
mitnehmen und er befeuert die debatte um
geschlechter unabhängige gleichbezahlung
der dfb und die deutsche fußball liga
dfl müssen jetzt den rahmen schaffen
wieder nach der heim wm 2011 noch nach
dem olympiagold 2016 war das gelungen
das ist sehr schade dass es so war und
ich hoffe dass wir tatsächlich auch mit
dem bundesliga auftakt da noch euphorie
setzen können für euphorie hat dieses
team bei den fans gesorgt jetzt müssen
verbände und politik gemeinsam den
frauenfußball in deutschland
voranbringen
ein schönes bild so dass war das heute
journal an diesem montag um mitternacht
meldet sich christopher wehrmann mit
unserem heute-journal update und morgen
an dieser und dieser stelle christian
sievers und hanna zimmermann wir sagen
tschüss und wünschen ein fan hand
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter extreme dürren hitze und
waldbrände die klimakrise spürt man
derzeit überall in europa und die hitze
setzt sich weiter fort 45 grad über
spanien werden morgen erwartet ein teil
dieser hitze wandert dann richtung
frankreich und dann nach deutschland und
erreicht uns dann am donnerstag schauen
auf die nacht und da gibt es südlich der
donau schauer und gewitter sonst klart
es teilweise auf und die temperaturen
sinken im norden auf 7 grad und im
südwesten auf 17 grad im süden generell
milder als im norden deutschlands morgen
dort dann einige schauer ansonsten
trocken vor allem viel sonnenschein nach
osten hin und auch nach südwesten
ja und die temperaturen erreichen an der
ostsee 22 grad hier also deutlich
erträglicher als zum beispiel im
südwesten 32 grad auch im rhein main
gebiet noch 31 grad die kommenden tage
am mittwoch bis zu 37 grad heiß und viel
sonnenschein am donnerstag daran dem
südwesten bis zu 40 grad und auch
richtung berlin und brandenburg 37 bis
38 grad ja und am freitag wird diese
hitze dann langsam verdrängt von
nordwesten her mit heftigen gewittern
teils im unwetter bereich und damit ein
schöner amt